And the correct answer here is that the running time of Bob's algorithm is 2^n  n²,
which is just the same running time as the algorithm that Alice was using,
and the reasons are also very similar.
If you have n genes, then again there's 2^n assignments of 0 and 1 to the genes,
and checking if an assignment is valid, so checking if all genes that have a 1 are connected
will also take O(n²).
That, of course, depends a bit on how many 1's there are in the assignment,
but a worst-case analysis would be here that close to n genes have been assigned 1,
so we need to check all of their connections which similar to Alice's algorithm,
you already know there are about n² many of them.
Bob, similar to Alice, has so far only found an algorithm that is totally impractical
for the problem that he's trying to solve because it has exponential running time.